you're alive good afternoon everybody
Sunday afternoon testing a new format of
tea with Gary B I'm your host Gary
Vaynerchuk this is like water with Gary
B on a Sunday afternoon pretty excited
got some questions lined up from the
audience also if you're watching on
YouTube LinkedIn Facebook and Twitter
live right now please leave comments let
me know what you think of this format
and how it's coming across to you and
and comments about the show itself and
what you like a big shout out hope
everybody's families are healthy and
secure hope everybody is starting to
process and get settled into a new
reality hope everybody is starting to
find their way and see their
opportunities and be grateful and humble
and let's get into the show all right
Dustin I'm ready for my first question
looking forward to it here we go hi oh
you know audio can't hear you yep just
make sure you prep people on audio nope
okay I'll keep yapping so everybody
let's see what's going on on Twitter if
you don't know this little fun fact
about me Twitter is absolutely the place
besides two one two nine three one five
seven three one Twitter's by far - place
where you get the most responses for me
hello nope
and it is no question this is why we're
doing a little test run on Sunday
afternoon little impromptu test run new
format and so I'm excited that that
we're getting through some of these
glitches right what's your name
Leslie such a pleasure awesome so my
question to you is how do you stay in
your lane when you want to try different
things that you don't necessarily have
enough knowledge on it like what would
you talk about on all different
platforms the process you know okay well
the expert is the only way to go and I
have I
documenting the journey to becoming
expert is actually potentially more
fascinating I think oh yeah
one boy like 22 year-old 24 year old me
of like learning wine and learning
marketing in the trendy would have been
fascinating content
so when you say document the journey of
becoming because I heard you say that in
one of the other videos yeah let's talk
about you
what new what do you let's talk about
what you trying to get into so I it's a
couple of things I really want to learn
how to direct music videos okay
and but I also like I did what you said
create a podcast well man it's a
visionaries tale I've been trying to get
guests on there but with my dog she's
not helping me record but my like I also
love getting to know people and their
process behind their vision and
everything you know and that's kind of
what the podcast is about but couple
things first of all yeah notes what the
dog situation if you're saying that the
dog is barking sometimes bothering you I
actually think that makes your podcast
more charming no [ __ ] like I think okay
I think production and yeah under think
humanity yeah you don't think I yeah
see where I'm going think about I do
well we're starting to know each other
better because they're you know my mom's
curtains are in the background like
people like club like real [ __ ] so okay
well listen people always have excuses
but you don't strike me as an excuse
person but it's sometime the dog is not
[ __ ] you are yeah it's not and like I
had all these questions prepared and
when I was trying to record like she was
just growling at me messing with the
laptop but hell yeah I will do it so
reviewing people that have made music
videos like you should TM 4,000 people
right now celeb celebrities influencers
tastemakers athletes rappers culture
models like everybody's responding to
more DMS and more lives they are yeah I
actually do people but I guess
it's like and I don't want to take up
too much time but how exactly like who
is the target then I say start at the
top and then work your way down but for
me it's like I've been reaching out to
local videographers that I want to get
to know more of but should you take the
chance and like Cole Bennett or Taj
Stansberry cuz pulls a good kid and he
might just be in a lyrical lemonade kind
of mindset that moment yeah because
there is no chance like that was a very
important moment of course you can take
a chance you should the chance it up for
an you know like like it's like what's
gonna happen your feelings got hurt that
Pharrell didn't yeah yeah you know the
we frame it you can definitely yes if
you don't ask yeah and like listening to
your content I stopped necessarily
caring about [ __ ] like been posting my
truth and my authentic self on Instagram
and all platforms
I lost a lot of followers but I have
been engaging more with other people and
I think that shit's sake so thank you
Gary you're welcome it's always depth
over with I'd rather have 837 people who
give a [ __ ]
than 8,000 that don't all right man
thank you so much dude I appreciate it
really good question
really good question right mom delivery
hey hey annalee um thanks for being here
to answer my question my question for
you was I'm a product designer and I'm
looking at starting a business and I'm
not sure if I should separate my
business from my personal social media
accounts and my blog I'm not sure people
will be interested in what I'm selling
or if it's gonna be bothersome I think I
think I think so what is the so one more
time your personal accounts what is the
business gonna be so I'm looking to get
into gift and novelty products well and
my passion that's what I love you're
clearly account social media accounts
for that business right yeah and then
what I would do is I would spur out
things about that you know in your
personal profile but not make it all of
this stuff so for example I'm putting
out all sorts of content all the time to
bring value and what what I'm looking to
do is is really try to I'm sorry I'm
doing a private chat so I'm testing some
new stuff Dustin I thought I was private
chatting you but I'm private chatting
Varela
so that's kind of interesting so we need
to figure that part out simile um the
the thing that you're gonna do is what I
kind of do with wine text right so I
share my normal stuff which is try to
bring new value and everybody else but
once in a while for my dad's business
I'll post something and say sign up for
wine text you're gonna do the same thing
you're gonna create an account for the
business but occasionally on your own
personal definitely the first day like
you're gonna pound all your personal
accounts and say hey I've started this
new business it would mean the world to
me if you could check it out and maybe
even pick up something if you're
interested and then a week later you can
say man this is tough doing this new
thing here's my business you know so I
think it's 3 to 30% of your content for
the first you know a couple of months of
its launch that will go really well ok
that's really helpful and then one other
question is I have a blog that kind of
relates to the product that I'm hoping
to sell and I'm just wondering should I
leverage the blog and like have the
product for sale on the blogger so they
just completely rebuilt the website for
that one more time I apologize I'm
testing out a new platform and I just
realized I have the live chat button so
Dennis Weber and stove and Gonzalo Henry
you I'm getting excited so I apologize
in elite more time no no worries Alan so
my question for you was I have a blog
that relates to kind of gift and novelty
and DIY and I thought I could use that
as a platform to sell the product but
I'm not sure if that's the right Avenue
to go or if I should just have a
completely new web
say definitely sell in that world
because that's a very close correlation
and again it's about jabs and right
hooks right the reason I wrote that book
is that you can give give give and then
once in a while you ask and there's
nothing wrong for asking with business
what's wrong is manipulating people into
buying [ __ ] not yeah after you've
provided value and the other
vulnerability that people have is when
they ask and and most people don't sign
up for it or buy it they get
disappointed they have expectations they
say I've had this blog for a year I've
given you so much value and why didn't
any of you [ __ ] buy my stuff and the
reality is you can't have that
expectation you're asking you're not
demanding so as long as you're
comfortable with politely asking and
dealing with however many you get then
you'll be super fine awesome thank you
so much you're welcome you're welcome
Italy take care of yourself you too
thank you comments are coming and I love
this Corey Kimball so you're able to see
like all these comments on the side yep
good yeah I can see Mitch I can't do
anything with them but I'm loving it I
can shows where it's coming from right
so yeah and they on on YouTube you know
XY rbn on YouTube
tipping picnic on periscope this is
great Paula Clark what's good go didn't
any Jersey Nicole what's up blood this
good channel to everybody there we go oh
no funeral we're gonna keep working on
it we're gonna help you we're gonna get
you back on I promise we're gonna keep
trying um Joey what's good how's it
going super well where you from love it
what's good man okay so over winter
break yep I got like really into
tick-tock and for like a month I grinded
on it and I actually like exploited me
and I'm like I gained a following and
over like the past month I got like
upwards of like I got I think I reached
like three hundred thousand which is
awesome but then like recently kind of
like out of nowhere it's just like I hit
a plateau it was like going up
it just like stopped you know going down
and so happening to a lot of people you
know why is it because a market
saturated or that's what I figured
brother this is why I was [ __ ] yelling
like a [ __ ] eighteen months ago
like go go go go yeah yeah it's like
real estate let me give you the comp
Joey it's like a part of Chicago suburb
starts getting hot and it goes from kind
of ghetto to going to rich area and you
can buy up [ __ ] and the houses are fifty
thousand at first and then when
everybody [ __ ] figures it out all of a
sudden miraculously the house is 150
thousand that's in money terms in real
estate that's what happens with
attention on social networks yeah all
the kids are coming back from college
and they're just scrolling through
social media all the time in tick-tock
itself is just exploding yeah that's
true ya know so so like my my original
question was like I kind of like just
stick to my niche I guess and so do you
what is your niche so my niece is uh
it's like an eight-year-old kid figuring
out stuff about the real world [ __ ]
money so I like I dress up like an
eight-year-old kid and then like I kind
of comedian when you get older I'm
honestly not sure like I'm a creative
musical type person that's a super
creative concept I [ __ ] love that so
yeah I I'm like an eight-year-old kid
figuring out about the real world and
then like I kind of gradually expanded
it into like a niche about kinda like a
family sitcom on tick-tock but the
problem is is that none of my videos
again before you page for like the last
two or three weeks and I don't know
whether I should like switch it up a
little bit or I should I would probably
do both I would maintain that sitcom but
I would become like a become like Dave
Chapelle like the Dave Chappelle show
like the Nokia and then just okay that
makes sense so now you do like a little
thing to kind of keep the audience going
and then keep it intact okay that makes
sense right cuz now create another
character like the douchebag DJ and do
it like and then create like literally
literally literally SNL the [ __ ] out of
your channel just make a tie characters
all this stuff keep it going when the
creativity to create the eight-year old
you probably have the creativity for
four to five other things you know you
can do that makes it is that mixes it up
it also makes us wait more
i watch in living color just waiting for
me the clown and some weeks it wasn't on
in some weeks it wasn't I think that's
where you can find your creativity
including your sixth you know if you
think about it it's eight year old it's
the DJ it's the father it's the old lady
character and then it's just actually
you Joey
and just like a video of like yo so this
is how I've been thinking about my
snitch like you can fourth-wall like you
could do it all you're in [ __ ] control
okay that makes sense yeah Beauty all
right perfect
all right man thank you so much we're
here to give tactics give real [ __ ]
advice on team with Gary Vee its mindset
and it's [ __ ] execution clouds and
dirt if you don't have both everybody's
got [ __ ] ideas nobody gives a [ __ ]
about it your idea ideas are great and
they're the way the world turns but
guess what if you don't execute on your
ideas the [ __ ] [ __ ] people hide
behind ideas because they don't want to
[ __ ] execute because they're scared
to put themselves out there because
they're fear-based because the word
about other people's judgments and
people literally [ __ ] don't live
their lives based on other people's
opinions and I've been put on this
[ __ ] earth to suffocate the [ __ ] out
of that conversation
I guess I'm extremely well how are you
I'm great because I don't even care if
you don't answer my question I have to
tell you you may have
she needed a teenager because you were
in Minnesota a couple summers ago and we
came up to see you from Wisconsin and
she was like 15 at the time and I was
kind of hoping okay well maybe Gary I'll
inspire her with income or something
like that generating money and actually
you said to the audience so what are you
gonna do are you gonna give up on your
happiness because you're too afraid of
having a tough conversation with a mom
dad grandparents so instead you're gonna
do what they want you to do instead of
trying what you want to try and she just
like I can't even tell you she brings
you up all the time
she literally we're listening to you
this week on Wednesday morning while we
were making breakfast and she's like mom
when this thing's over can we please go
see Gary again
like we need to go here I love that guy
so I hope you go out on the road again
because we're gonna come and find you
somewhere yes you don't even know like
that makes me feel yeah it was seriously
I I don't think you can possibly
understand how important that message
was for her in her life what their
answer for you okay so I quit teaching
about just under two years ago and
decided to go all in on my content
writing business and got really really
blessed got some great retainer clients
and now in the past like nine to ten
months I really started shifting towards
copywriting and I'm good and I'm really
trying to master the craft getting up
early practicing doing all that kind of
stuff
but now I'm seeing how I need to not
just rely on referrals and word of mouth
I need to start building an audience but
then of course Crone virus is hit and
I'm just kind of like I'm trying to
master the craft I'm trying to get new
clients going online and I'm just kind
of struggling with what do i prioritize
where do I spend my time that kind of
stuff I think you spend your time on
putting out on sample work engaging with
people starting a Facebook group of
small business owners in the Minnesota
suburb what I think most people don't
understand is that business is human and
it's about humanity and people and so I
think the number one thing that you need
to really think about is just building a
community and getting people to know you
like you know moms moms dealing with
this you know in a Facebook group and
you get to know Sarah and Cleveland
through it and then when this is over or
even later when we get into like what do
you do like literally being the kind of
person online that is really good at a
cocktail party where you're not handing
out your business card to everybody and
trying to get everybody to just do
business with you
you're just genuinely being human
talking about the weather talking about
Corona talking about sports talking
about getting back to real life talking
about kids and husbands and just being a
human and then inevitably in that
conversation it comes around to by the
way what do you do and so
I think it's content and community right
putting out content what kind of content
it could be a million things you making
a video of just why you decided to get
into copywriting and just posting it out
on your Facebook and Instagram if 87
people watch it it begins the process
and then I think joining a ton of groups
I think one of the great things that
people don't talk about is virtual
networking starting up Google hang-ups
hangouts and zooms and other things that
nature just being the community leader
like literally posting on your Facebook
right now like do 10 people want to get
you know a happy hour with me tonight
and just shoot the [ __ ] you know and
like you know I'll send out the Google
hangout link I think networking just
being a human is a huge backer thank you
you're welcome
take your Jeff alright um lesson get on
here what we can see right yep so that's
a couple things one the comments that
you've been flashing down here I love
that okay we can make them sit there
longer or when you flash that's how long
they said no they can sit for a while
it's just uh I want to get people to
plow and these it's all right like you
know I would have loved it if I was
watching random watching at Sabbath
doing here live 20 years ago and you
pinned my comment so AI want to do that
um be a lot of people I see in the
comments and a live stream are trying to
figure out how this works so a but you
can if you see people putting up
questions I don't mind you throwing that
up not just nice comments okay like
utility questions not an actual question
because that's what the people in the
screen before team Gary if you're
watching this right now which I know you
are in periscope and YouTube a lot of
places a lot of questions are like
what's the format how do I get on the
show I want to do a lot more community
management in the streams helping people
there's just a ton a ton of questions so
let's do that
I like the rotation that you're doing
you know will work by you on the share
this slide I think that's super [ __ ]
rad I like the phone number I like so
like a nice healthy mix I would say 30
seconds on the comments you'll do it
about five before yeah it was just more
of like me just kind of experimenting
see
yeah let's truck let's do let me go in
there
question just do 5 10 15 and 20 second
intervals of just all comments while I'm
on let's see what that's feels oh cool
awesome let's get this going okay let's
try it again hear me oh my gosh third
time's a charm how's it going Gary may
your someday going oh well how are you
good good good it's a little bit delay
but that's okay I'm will work with it
what can I answer for you so I am a
wedding planner perfect time to do that
I'm also in the middle of construction
which is where I am right now
we were just scraping floor so the
flooring could come on Monday but my
question is not for me it's actually for
my entire community I live in a little
town called Wisconsin Dells whoo-hoo
shout out to my town we are a tourism
capital of the Midwest known for water
parks big group conventions day trippers
overnight safe so right now we're taking
a really big hit because all of my
friends everybody that I know it they're
either a owner or they're employed by
one so I know social media can be a
really big help
matter of fact the last networking event
that I attended was a bunch of owners
wondering how can they even get started
with social media and now they have
plenty of time so my question for you is
as a community what do we do to have a
campaign or something that can unify us
because our customers are not here our
customers are in Chicago Minnesota all
over the states so what can we do right
now so when this is all over we can have
a recovery plan it's about building
awareness to people that don't know
about you and creating stickiness with
the people that you so things that run
through my mind if I'm a water park in
the area I'm thinking about obviously
I'm worried about my employees I'm
worried about myself but what can I do
for the community
is a donation I can do is there
something nice I can do can I build up
some temporary testing sessions like a a
what can I do for the world be the next
thing I'm thinking about is producing
content around the stories the reality
of our place so I would immediately go
into story time make three four
different videos about how my
grandfather started it you know where we
started it what was the first
breakthrough the top times the the good
times the bad times legitimately stories
then I would start doing also jeans and
record them with the 25 50 employees or
people in the community record them just
shooting the [ __ ] and literally just
take like our own conversation telling
everybody we're recording this and we're
gonna put it on YouTube literally it's
about creating content to build
awareness of the area because the
reality is the core business is not
going to be hearing out but you know I
can't hear you anymore I'm gonna give
the answer and we're gonna move on so
the reality right now during this time
is to tell stories to get people to know
about your place and so when your
business is when your restaurant right
now or a convention center or anything
affected so aggressively by this a
wedding planner you know right now is
the time to story tell about you to the
world this is the time to set up an
account on every platform and create
content content content so that people
are aware so when this is over you have
a better chance of getting some of the
back some things you just can't navigate
through there they're just ironclad and
right now what is ironclad is people are
not going to large gatherings and and so
if you look at what the NBA is doing
they're thinking about playing course at
home they're doing video game stuff it's
just about contouring this time okay so
hopefully I can watch the line so I love
this big shout out to Susan Keely Seth
Bieber
Carla Henderson Hendrickson excuse me
all on Facebook right now alumnus
Charles Clark my man YouTube community I
appreciate you being here Marcus J care
what's good what's up Gary are you doing
well what's your name Mike Mike
real pleasure yeah yeah I've been trying
to talk to you for the last year dude
glam on me yeah yeah yeah yeah leave my
friend Brad Smith used to play for the
Jets Missouri right Nakamura at one
point I was like yo Brad how can you get
me in a room with Gary ya maniac in
2009/10 those were for success big shut
up Brad Pitt
absolutely yeah yeah Brad not getting
same shirt
yeah yeah so here's my question so yeah
I am
I'm an entrepreneur and I'm an educator
so I work at a school that uses adaptive
learning software in place of direct
instruction so there's no math teacher
there's a math app right science out
what that does is that shorten is the
school day the academic portion that be
only two hours and the rest of the day
is spent learning life skills and do it
like like interest based projects right
so like we can do things that nobody
else can do like I actually taught a a
workshop to kids about how to flip
sports cards on eBay right so for six
weeks kids were like stealing stuff from
their parents looking around a bit right
do like issue at the model is that that
right now education like this is not
sustainable for low-income communities
so I'm trying to figure out like what is
a revenue model or like a profit Mawson
business model that you think could make
this how much is accessible right now
we're near enough
gotcha okay right now we're $13,000 a
year and then twenty four thousand for
high school
I actually I'm back I lost you so I mean
I could hear both of you but kind of
strange I can't hear you but try again I
can hear like it sounds good yeah well
if the live he can hear you you just
answer I'll check them with you it might
it might be the ones whoever has the
kids in the background just add 30 okay
because then if there's like two
different noises it kind of like cancels
the other person out barely let me see
what I can do
oops one two one two one two one two
there you are yeah you can hear me
yeah I can't hear you Mike oh I mean new
platform life Dustin you can hear me
yeah here both of you my canyon Jackie
here you okay yeah I could hear my call
so early
so if you go on the bottom go to kam mic
and then go to audio except yep now I
can hear you yeah yeah yeah so how much
is the cost so thirteen thousand for K
through eight and then twenty four
thousand high school per year for you
alright you got to go into fundraising
for scholarships you got to go into
corporate America and see if Chase Bank
or or Salesforce you got a [ __ ] grind
if you can't drive down the cost if you
can't discount it to lower income then
you need to figure out how to go
directly into high net worth individuals
and organizations and get scholarships
or something that I think could work
when I think about an app you can start
picking things like Cisco and s AP and
sales first you see where I'm going all
this said I'm thinking mmm
Marc Benioff is one of the best foods on
earth when it comes to entrepreneur and
giving a [ __ ] is his company capable of
writing a ten million dollar check which
goes ham for a fuckload of kids
subsidizing through people who can
afford it around feeling good about
themselves looking for the clout or
corporate objectives real talk talk to
you soon can't wait to meet ya in person
alright I'm gonna be wrapping up here in
a second
let's get you got one more for me Dustin
Rhonda Williams what's good there we got
two and two the cute all right let's
bang about real fast okay oh hey Tom
where you from I'm tato very nice to
meet you
you see so good quick question um so my
parents
the dentist they forced me to go to
dental school I'm in my third year so
I'm almost done so I can hate
yes and I can't do it really do anything
about it I didn't extend why not yeah
and yeah so I really do hate it on each
day it's really hard and whatnot so I'm
like even when I graduate I'm not sure
if I actually want to actually be a
dentist so I don't you don't Tom listen
to me Tom there is no way on earth that
you can be a dentist you [ __ ] hate it
mm-hmm you have to be 36 years old and
you're gonna resent your parents for
your whole life you're gonna resent them
yeah that's wrong yeah sucks yeah you
you already have underlining resentment
towards the home yes I do yeah and you
love your you love your parents yes yes
I do and my mom she wants me to take
over her dental practice because she is
a ownable in practice so yeah there's
that
convocation too so no yeah I will go to
Toronto and put you out of business and
start my own dental practice if you do
that no you can't do that
mm-hm you're Tom you're gonna be you're
gonna be sad yes yeah I know I'm already
very sad it's a taking tonight can I
help you mm-hmm okay number one Tom
you're not gonna be a dentist mm-hmm I
promise you you will not mm-hmm number
two do the next year and change of how
long are you in dental school for I have
one more year but because of the corne
advice yeah I mean me yeah you're gonna
treat that year differently than you
treated every other year you're gonna
enjoy yourself and it's gonna be your
last vacation you're gonna treat it as a
vacation you're gonna try to pass of
course yeah you're not gonna stress as
much and you're gonna enjoy your
downtime you're gonna study a little
less and you're gonna have more fun and
then you're gonna come out of school and
you're gonna tell your parents you're
not taking over to dental practice and
they will be upset and they won't mom
will cry mom will cry she'll cry and dad
or mom
be like you're an idiot you're bad for
12 months for 24 months for 36 months
but you cannot be a dentist Tom it's the
most obvious thing I've ever seen in my
life you hate it mm-hmm yes yes yeah I
was thinking like what I could do after
hey I really like film and whatnot so
move to California get a shitty job and
get into the game yeah yeah that's what
I was thinking of doing like that wait
can you offer some like that yeah that's
right mm-hmm
Thomas you better listen to me cuz I
don't believe that you're gonna listen
to me I'm gonna keep you on a little
longer listen to me upsetting your
parents for a short period of time so
that you can have the love forever is
much more fun than making them fake
happy for a period of time and then
hating them forever mm-hmm yes yes yeah
yeah I know you said that numerous times
before yeah I do understand but do you
want me do you want me to come with you
do you want me to fly home with you and
windows I will come I'll come with you
and I will hold your hand and we'll tell
your parents we're not [ __ ] gonna
become dentists or parents no I already
told them but they're like yeah it's
accurate the immigrant parent they're
saying that it can be realistic what
else can I do and whatnot yeah yeah I
don't like it I don't like him being
selfish calm they're doing the wrong
thing they love you yes they're being
selfish
they're wrong mm-hmm Tom do you want me
to come with you and sit with your
parents and drink some tea and tell them
what's up I think I'm okay though thank
you for the offer
do you want to FaceTime me in when we
start conversating and I'll sit there
and give them a piece of my mind
uh uh uh yeah maybe sometime in the
future okay Thomas to me I'm Robbie see
playing around here a little bit I know
this is difficult I know it's difficult
but I promise on all my heart I promise
mm-hmm
you can't become a dentist it will be
the worst decision of your life
I was thinking maybe I could do it
part-time is it no no no you're not
gonna be a dentist
oh the only reason you're gonna do that
is because you love your parents yeah
and you respect your parents I'm telling
you - you're beautiful young face you're
gonna end up hating them mm-hmm no do
you want to hate your parents no no I
don't that's right I know you don't
so listen to me you're on the verge of
hating them because you're gonna blame
them and resent them your whole life you
are I don't know if I've ever seen
somebody hate something more than I've
seen you hate dentist mm-hmm
you [ __ ] hate it I can feel it I've
good chemicals like that you can't be a
dentist yes
you can't not part time not sometimes
not over the summer nothing it's over
yes brother you can't do it yeah your
parents will love you and I'm gonna tell
you something very powerful very
powerful mmm your parents will respect
you more for not doing it then doing it
mm-hmm it doesn't feel like that now
mm-hmm listen I'm from a parents I live
in immigrant circles I know this isn't
easy I know that Americans and Canadians
don't understand it's a different
culture I know I know
mm-hmm but I'm telling you right now I
know so many 55 year old Tom's that are
doctors lawyers engineers and dentists
and they are not in a good place they're
alcoholics drug users they have no
relationship with their parents and and
if it's not those three things they're
just sad and that's the worst of the
[ __ ] four of them mm-hmm yeah you
have to have courage to do this yeah
yeah
two to two to three bad years two to
three bad years and a lifetime of a good
relationship with your parents versus
versus a lifetime of not a good
relationship with your parents
mmm-hmm your parents are scared they
want you to be safe there they're over
coddling you Mama's gonna give you the
business it's gonna be okay you can get
married and how I can have grandchildren
she's being selfish Tom if I [ __ ]
find out that you became a dentist I
swear to [ __ ] god I'm gonna go up to
that dentistry and I'm gonna cause
[ __ ] havoc listen to me Tom you know
my phone number to one two nine three
one five are you in Canada right I think
it works again I think it works in
Canada listen to me listen to me
use me not believe that we accomplished
you not being a dentist here I think
we're gonna we're gonna hang up okay and
you're and you're and you're still gonna
be a part-time dentist and I don't like
that feeling right now I don't want that
for you brother you're gonna resent them
you're gonna be unhappy mm-hmm yes yeah
do me a favor we watch this video every
day yep I wrote it start editing start
playing start reaching out start DMing
people that make content in LA mm-hmm if
you need help I know a lot of directors
and producers in LA I will help you
thank you Tom are you gonna be a
part-time dentist tell you the truth tom
hey yeah I know what I need us initially
I was thinking part-time dentist and
part-time like exploring filming my
hobbies ooh
my interest in what thoughts um so I
have something to like pay for the bills
and whatnot but well yeah I'm a bit
unsure at the moment but I do agree with
you I have thought about Lake North
becoming a dentist after and just
dropping here but then it's like my
mind's all over the place sometime I
would say your part-time dentist
sometime I'll say just you out there
completely and the Superdome and it's
like yeah it's a bit it was also
paraprofessionals and they went on but
yeah listen to me
is not success happiness is success
mm-hmm yes you have you have to have to
have to have to have to go to Los
Angeles get a shitty job in
entertainment mm-hmm start networking in
that world mm-hmm yeah I would be so
proud of you if you were receptionist or
an assistant or an intern of the intern
in Hollywood more than [ __ ] getting a
job as a [ __ ] dentist mm-hmm yeah I
know that this is more like I don't
because I'm Canadian and due to visa
stuff I need like a job offer before but
that's the good news good news time
Toronto and Vancouver good [ __ ] job
yeah Tyler has a lot and Vancouver and
it's [ __ ] nice out there
mm-hmm yes your parents what are your
parents live we live in Toronto I think
in the suburbs yeah okay Tom you need to
go to Vancouver mm-hmm yes yeah I
escaped from you you need to go to
Vancouver okay how do I do that
hold on one second hey Brandon I'll call
you right back on why text I'm sitting
you're fixing tom from Toronto's life on
blood stream we're telling him not to be
a Brandon can you can you please tell
him not to be a dentist he's here that
tom is my best friend Brandon who's know
me since Brennan
you know me since I was 14 tell Tom how
often I'm right and Tom this is not the
point two percent of the time I love you
play that Tom yeah I want to be a Coover
and you're slipping around lighting or
doing some [ __ ] thing and you're
gonna be the happiest [ __ ] ever mm-hmm
where you gonna stay in Toronto and
[ __ ] be miserable mm-hmm yes thank
you you're welcome tom [ __ ] I think
everybody just fell in love with Tom
man I wasn't
I mean blink how the [ __ ] are you gonna
follow that I know right except you know
we tried to push our kids to be Dennis
but you're joking oh please tell me
that's a truth yeah that's the truth
yeah did you hear my rear mom the next
guy on goes we tried to push our kids to
be dentists that's awesome but they
didn't listen to you no they had a lot
of clients that were dentist and we're
like yeah these guys are killing it and
so we thinking we want our kids to be
finished you know but I really I get
again how are you what can I help you
with well man we're in a I started my
company in 2013 when a home inspection
company we've grown to 39 employees and
we're just killing it every year we were
first quarter we were a fifty-four
percent year-over-year and of course now
with this lock down you know
everything's just gone to [ __ ] we can
still work but you know people are just
not buying houses they're sitting on the
sidelines of course that we've pivoted
with that I said of course that makes
sense yeah so we kind of pivoted so we
did some research and we came up with a
decontamination service or we can go in
and decontaminate houses before people
move in and so that's that's helping to
bring in a little bit of revenue but now
I'm just trying to grab market share and
I love your mindset of abundance and you
know we try to keep that but we're just
trying to figure out the best way to
grab market share now even though it's
not going to generate revenue so 90% of
our referrals come from Realtors and so
that's who we work with
have you started where's your business
where are you based
we're in Dallas Fort Worth and Austin I
love it so I would start a small
business or even a real estate Facebook
group immediately
I would post on all your social networks
whether personal for the business that
you're hosting zoom and Google hangout
sessions every night happy hours yep
businesses become the host of the party
of the discussion in real estate agents
real estate and insurance brokers you
know banks entrepreneurs become the
mayor of your town virtually become the
Pied Piper that hosts virtual happy
hours and parties every night people
will become aware of you it's networking
there's 50 people on the screen just
talking [ __ ] you're the [ __ ] head of
the table okay Rick what do you got
where you from become become the Pied
Piper become the host every night Blake
I'm not kidding immediately this Monday
7 p.m. on on this link on Google I'm
hosting a party for all real estate
agents
you know construction you know
developers we're just gonna shoot the
[ __ ] for Dallas area you know real
estate professionals bring your bottle
of wine bring a beer bring a cocktail
bring a coffee we're gonna shoot the
[ __ ] [ __ ] and that to me
I guess Blake didn't like the advice
Blake you didn't like that I'm kidding
I'm kidding Blake he's still there but
I'm not sure that's okay Blake pardon
yeah no worries brother now that sounds
become the host of the party it will
work it will work because you're gonna
build awareness that's awesome every
night you know 7:00 to 9:00 p.m. you
know Dallas or Texas name it Texas real
estate professionals you know happy
hours and just be the host and make it
invite only people have to hit you up
and you got to prove them it could be a
whole [ __ ] thing throw the party it's
the highschool party rule whoever had
the house to throw the party became
cooler in high school your way of
becoming cooler is that do you
understand
Godse yeah and yeah and you don't even
and you don't even need your parents to
go away for the weekend it's called
[ __ ] Google hangout
zooom alright man
I mean talk to you soon thank you
alright I'm getting out of here I really
appreciate everybody YouTube Facebook
periscope Twitter Linkedin I appreciate
all of you Dustin get in here for a
second
oops oh pretty pretty good format what
were you seeing a lot I was trying to
keep track of the comments but they are
going by so fast that it's sure yeah and
then the same time just having the
people come in I don't see LinkedIn
comments on the comments was it
screaming on LinkedIn it was yeah I
don't see them coming in either so I'll
double check on that
after the stream is over okay let's go
into the team Gary group and let's uh
let's figure this out I think you'll be
watching tomorrow Oh tea with Gary be
looking forward to it
set your RSVPs we'll put it out right
now on all our social say your alarms
get in here with us tomorrow tea with
Gary B 9:00 a.m. Eastern 6:00 a.m. in
the West Coast get up get up and get at
it
we'll see you tomorrow love you